it matters if her deal vote goes down
next Tuesday an awful lot because it
greatly could restrict the amount of
time that she has to seek any further
reassurances it had not been expected by
the government Whip's office all the
labor what's office that this could be
selected but it has been by speaker
Berko and it means that the sort of
slightly close to home consequence for
me is that my panel will have to
disappear within Prime Minister's
Questions so let's bring them in whilst
we've still got them but it's worth just
emphasizing Ben Bradlee the
Conservatives that this is supposed to
be a nun amendable motion the government
the privilege of being government is you
set the agenda for legislation and for
hundreds of years that's been the case
if the speaker feels that he can do what
you know both whips offices thought and
I still think he's out of order then
that has huge implications going forward
as to government control and ability to
to make laws will likely succeed
probably point of order on this only
because the speaker you think the
speaker would have to explain a lot
imagine the speaker would probably
explain I mean equally the speaker was
undoubtedly have found something in a
spin maze the guidebook for the
conference that will be the backing for
this but every night some of the people
who put their name on this amendment let
me let me read out who it is it's
Dominic Reeve sort of a let's win Steven
Doughty Joe Johnson and a super-ego to
babe Sam Jima and the like Philippa Lee
Justine greening I mean I speaking to
one of these signatories who said well
it's in order now it's going to be voted
on in the next sort of just after prime
misses questions who think I mean I'm
not an expert in asking may you need
Chris Brian for that but I you know the
speak would have taken legal advice on
this so you know you'll have to believe
that he is able to do this so you know
we'll have to see where the points of
order what his explanation is and you
know we are in unprecedented time so
sorry an attorney from Labor Party let's
again bring in Emily pengelley from the
DGP the fact is that it's your
opposition
there is opening out the difficulties
for the Prime Minister isn't it I mean
is there a point where you compromise is
I think that the reasons why we are not
happy with the restoral agreement is
actually reason shared by many people
including many within the Conservative
Party but also people right across the
House of Commons so it's not just the
DEP here and I think that's important
that the union matters to people right
across the house and right across in
anything Thank You Emma let's go past
Commons where Prime Minister has started
the first Prime Minister's a 2090 in
paying tribute to Lord Paddy Ashdown who
sadly died last month from his service
in the Royal Marines through to his time
in this house and then as High
Representative for Bosnia and
Herzegovina he served his country with
passion and distinction and he will be
sorely missed in recent days Mr Speaker
we have seen instances of threats of
violence or intimidation against members
of this house including my right
honourable friend the member for Brock's
toe and members of the media I know the
whole house will join me in condemning
those threats politicians and the media
should be able to go about their work
without harassment and intimidation mr.
speaker this morning I had meetings with
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today her comments on Lord Paddy Ashdown
and of course the disgraceful behavior
of threats to politicians and
journalists going about their business
mr. speaker like those in the rest of
the UK 235 thousands EU nationals in
Scotland were treated to a Christmas
removal threat via social media from the
UK home office telling them to register
if they want to stay in the UK after
December 2020 friends neighbours
colleagues people vital to the Scottish
economy shamefully told to pee to stay
in their own homes
can she confirm what will happen to
those not registered by December 2020
and does she realize that for those
effective
this feels life's like a hostile
environment and more like a xenophobic
Minister can I say to the Honorable
gentleman we recognize the huge
contribution that he you citizens have
made to our economy and to our society
and we want them to stay in the EU
settlement scheme makes we'll make it
simple straightforward for them to get
the status that they need but can I say
to the honourable gentleman also EU
citizens have until June 2021 to apply
the cost of applying is less than the
cost of renewing a British passport but
if he is concerned about the interests
of EU citizens then he can back the deal
which enshrines the EU citizens rights
Tom pursglove mr. speaker the
government's commitment to the armed
forces covenant is commendable as is its
focus on reducing reoffending care after
combat it's doing remarkable work in
this area and their veterans have a
reoffending rate of 8% compared to a
national average on leaving prison that
45% saving the government 20 million
pounds will my right honourable friend
therefore convene across government
effort to not only shore up care after
combats work but to look to expand it
nationally very important issue in first
of all I'd like to pay tribute to those
who've served in our armed forces for
their courage and their commitment I'd
also like to pay tribute to the vital
work that care after combat undertakes
my honourable friend is absolutely right
on that now we have a range of measures
in place to support those who've served
in the Armed Forces who then find
themselves in the criminal justice
system and prisons Taylor rehabilitative
work to the individual needs helping to
reduce the risk of reoffending when
they're released from prison but the
point my humble friend makes about the
excellent record of care after combat is
a very good one and I'm sure that a
minister from the ministry of justice
will be happy to meet with him to
discuss this further Jeremy Corbyn
thank you Thank You mr. speaker I joined
the prime minister in paying tribute to
Paddy Ashdown he was elected to
Parliament at the same time as me in
1983 he was a very assiduous
constituency MP he was a very effective
Member of Parliament and he and I spent
a lot of evenings voting against what
the statutory government was doing at
that time I also mr. speaker agree with
the agree with the Prime Minister on the
point she made about intimidation of
members of Parliament's and
representatives of media outside this
building has happened a few days ago
when the member for Brock's toe and Owen
Jones the Guardian were intimidated
outside this building and I send my
support and sympathy to both of them but
we also have to be clear mr. speaker
that intimidation is wrong outside this
building as it is wrong in any other
aspect of life in this country and we
have to create a safe space a safe space
we have to create a safe space for
political debates
you see what I mean mr. speaker I'm
calling for a safe space for political
debate
[Applause]
although we've got a long way to go the
questions will be heard and the answers
will be heard no amount of heckling no
amount of noise will make any difference
to that simple fact Jeremy Corbyn Mr
Speaker I also sure the whole house
would join me in wishing a speedy
recovery to the two British soldiers who
were injured in Syria last week the
Prime Minister scraps the brexit vote
last month and promised legally binding
assurances would be secured at the
December au summit
she failed she pledged to get these
changes over the recess she failed isn't
the Prime Minister bringing back exactly
the same deal she admitted would be
defeated
four weeks ago can I first of all say to
the right honourable gentleman I
absolutely agree with him that there is
no place for intimidation in any part of
our society
politicians do need to be able to have a
safe space in which to express their
opinions many of which are passionately
held and I hope he will now ask his
shadow Chancellor
for the remarks that he made about the
former Secretary of State for Work and
Pensions
on the matter on the matter of brexit
that the right honourable gentleman has
raised perhaps I let me update the house
the conclusions of the December European
Council went further than before in
seeking to address the concerns of this
house and they have legal status I've
been in contact with European leaders
over since then about MPs concerns these
discussions have shown that further
clarification on the backstop is
possible and those talks will continue
over the next few days but we're also
looking at what more we can do
domestically to safeguard the interests
of the people and businesses of Northern
Ireland and that's why this morning we
published a package of commitments that
give Northern Ireland a strong voice and
role in any decision to bring the
backstop into effect we've also been
looking at how Parliament can take a
greater role as we take these
negotiations on to the next stage and so
I can tell the house that in the event
that our future relationship or
alternative arrangements are not ready
by the end of 2020 Parliament will have
a vote on whether to seek to extend the
implementation period or bring the
backstop into effect and the secretary
of state for exiting the european union
will be saying more about this during
his opening speech in the forthcoming
debate jeremy corbyn mr. speaker no
amount of window dressing is going to
satisfy members of this house they want
to see clear legal changes to the
document that the government presented
to this house the foreign secretary said
the Prime Minister has not been asking
for anything new in her discussions with
the European Union
she don't tell us so doesn't that tell
us that the Prime Minister has been
recklessly wasting time holding the
country to ransom with the threat of no
deal in a desperate attempt to blackmail
MPs to vote for her hopelessly unpopular
deal likes about No Deal
but he opposes any deal that the
government has Nico's
the European he opposes the deal he
opposes the deal that the EU say is the
only deal and that leaves him with No
Deal
the only way to avoid no deal is to vote
for the deal
[Music]
if the right honourable gentleman if the
right honourable gentleman is uncertain
about what I am saying perhaps I can
give him a tip he might like to use a
lip reader
from the prime minister says that it's
the only deal available if that is the
case why wasn't it put to a vote on
December the 11th in this house why is
the little delay of five weeks on this
the Prime Minister said she hopes to get
written assurances before the vote next
week so can I ask the prime minister
this will the changes she's looking for
be made the legally binding withdrawal
agreement itself we as I have said
earlier in my remarks and I've said
previously there are three elements that
we are looking at one is the
undertakings and assurances we are
looking for from the European Union and
those will be available we intend that
those will be available to the house
before the house votes at the end of
this debate we are also looking at what
more we can do domestically I've set out
there is the Secretary of State will be
clearer and more detail we'll set out
what we're going to do in relation to
the powers for Northern Ireland and in
relation to the question of the role of
parliament for the future and we will be
looking we are looking to ensure that we
can provide the assurance and confidence
that this house needs in relation in
relation to the question that has been
at the forefront of members concerns in
relation to the the backstop but we've
put a good deal on the table yes we are
looking for those clarifications
clarifications which I'm sure will
ensure when ensure that members of this
house know that the backstop need never
be used and that if you if it is used it
is only temporary that very long answer
I didn't hear the words legal changes to
the document that was what my question
was mr. speaker the Environment
Secretary has said no deal would damage
the UK farming sector the Foreign
Secretary has said that no deal is not
something any government would wish on
its people the 4.2 billion of public
money is being wasteful allocated to No
Deal planning will the Prime Minister
listen to the clearly expressed will of
the house
last night and this costly Sherrod and
rule out No Deal made it clear to the
right honourable gentleman but if he
wants to avoid No Deal he has to about a
deal a good deal but he stands there and
complains about money being spent on No
Deal preparation so today on Wednesday
he's saying we shouldn't be spending
money on No Deal preparations on Monday
he said No Deal preparations were too
little too late he can't have it both
ways either we're doing too much or were
doing too little so perhaps he can break
his usual habit and actually give us a
decision which is it this is the first
time since 1978
that a prime minister has been defeated
in the finance bill in the House of
Commons last night the house made it
clear in supporting the amendment in the
name of my friend the members the
Normans and Pontefract in Castleford
that no deal should be ruled out that is
the position of this house the UK
automotive industry has written to the
Prime Minister in December asking her to
take No Deal option off the table or
risk destroying this vital UK industry
given this house is now rejected No Deal
will the Prime Minister protect
thousands of skilled jobs in the
automotive industry and others and rule
out No Deal recognise that the right
honourable gentleman welcomed the
leadership that the right honourable
lady the members of normanton had given
on the issue that he's referred to I
just want to be clear that the amendment
does not change the fact that the UK is
leaving the European Union on the 29th
of March and nor does it stop the
government from collecting from
collecting tax but he asked once again
about the question of of No Deal and
about protecting jobs we have negotiated
a deal with the European Union that
protects jobs we only go
with the European Union but ensures what
is what is raising concerns what is
raising concerns he says is the prospect
of No Deal
it is absolutely sensible for this
government to prepare for No Deal and
those preparations are even more
important given the position taken by
the right honourable gentleman with an
opposition front bench that is opposed
to any deal that the government
negotiates with the European Union it's
even more important that we prepare for
no deal the deal protects jobs and
security and delivers on the referendum
and assured bakit mr. speaker instead of
backing industries in this country and
protecting thousands of jobs in
manufacturing and service industries her
transport secretary is awarding millions
of pounds of contracts to ferry
companies with no ferries to run on
routes that don't exist and apparently
they won't even be ready by the
beginning of April either this is the
degree of incompetence of this
government in dealing with the whole
question of relations with the EU the
Prime Minister has spent the last week
begging for warm words from EU leaders
and achieved nothing not one single dot
or comma has changed she's already
squandered millions of pounds of public
money on last-minute half-baked planning
for a No Deal that was rejected last
night so if her deal is defeated next
week as I hope and expect it will will
the Prime Minister do the right thing
and let the people have a real say and
call a general election
[Applause]
No we've put a good deal on the table
that protects jobs and security but I
noticed I noticed in all of that that we
still don't know what brexit man the
right honourable gentleman has I was
rather hoping as he went through that he
might turn over a page and actually find
a brexit plan because what do we know
about the right honorable gentleman he
been for and against free movement he's
been for and against the customs union
he's been for and against an independent
trade policy he was a euro skeptic now
he's probe the EU he wanted to trick a
lot of a 50 on day one now he wants to
delay it he didn't want money spent on
No Deal now he says it's not enough the
one thing we know about the right
honourable gentleman it's his present
policies or the many not the few
[Applause]
the HS long-term plan is hugely welcome
in particular its recognition that GPS
are the bedrock of the NHS does the
Prime Minister agree that it's vitally
important that we do all we can to
support GPS to stay in general practice
and that the education training budget
must be urgently prioritized to support
a wide range of healthcare professionals
to support GPS in their practices raises
a very important point about GPS and
indeed of course if he looks at the
long-term plan for the NHS which was
launched on Monday which is being made
possible by the 20 point 5 billion
pounds extra will be putting into the
NHS in 22 23 24 he will see that support
for the workforce including GPS is a
very important part of that plan and
indeed a higher greater focus on primary
care which would be better for people in
helping to keep them out of hospital at
any point in time 20 to 30% of people in
hospital don't need to be there is an
important part of that plan GPS and an
essential element of that I assure my
honourable friend that they will be part
of that important Workforce Planning
Riaan Blackford
Thank You mr. speaker can I concur with
the Prime Minister on her remarks and
Paddy Ashdown and make the point all of
us collectively have a responsibility to
make sure that there's no intimidation
in our public life mr. speaker the Prime
Minister delayed the doom brexit bought
last year on the promise of written
concessions from Brussels Prime Minister
Quinn Rd the position in my first
response to the leader of the Opposition
I suggest he should have listened to it
the in Blackbird worker used mr. speaker
not to getting an answer and there we
have it again what the Prime Minister
promised was that we would get written
concessions that Parliament would have
the opportunity to vote on that and
nothing has materialized a month has
passed and nothing has changed mr.
speaker last night the Prime Minister
suffered another humiliating defeat when
what the Prime Minister faced the facts
there is little support for her Deal or
No Deal in this house the new year began
without concessions the Dublin talks
failed without concessions the debate on
her deal restarts two days without
concessions mr. speaker the Prime
Minister it's frozen in failure asking
MPs to write a blank cheque for her
blindfold breakfast Maisie MP should not
be debating without the full facts is it
this or whether other concessions not
just clarifications when when the Prime
Minister guaranteed that this house will
see the full details before we start the
debate this afternoon
the Prime Minister as I said in response
to his first question I set out the
position the air I was referenced as he
will know the conclusions of the
December European Council which went
further in relation to the issues that I
have raised with the European Council
than they had gone before and those have
legal status but we are of course
working further on those on those issues
but the right honourable gentleman can't
get away from the fact that if he wants
to avoid no deal he has to be willing to
agree a deal the deal is on the table
the deal that is on the table that the
EU has made clear is the only deal is
the one that the United Kingdom
government has negotiated with the
European Union and if he really wants
and is concerned about ensuring that we
can look ahead with a bright future
across the whole of the United Kingdom
he should pack that deal closed question
Michel fabricant question 11 mr. speaker
Prime Minister thank you I was pleased
to make a meet the mayor of the West
Midlands last October when my right
honourable friend the Chancellor and I
visited the Kings Norton headquarters of
a DI group and we saw firsthand the
opportunities that apprenticeships can
afford and that's why we're seeing
annual investment in apprenticeships
double to nearly 2.5 billion by 2020 it
was also an excellent opportunity to see
a successful West Midlands company doing
its bit to give young people a career
and I'm pleased to say that the latest
statistics show employment in the West
Midlands has risen by two hundred and
seventy six thousand since 2010 Michael
fabricant
well that's fantastic news but I think
the Prime Minister will agree with me
that transport is also the key to
employment and I just want to raise the
question of the rail line which lies
between Litchfield and Burton which is
currently only used for freight it
passes the National Memorial Arboretum
which gets around half a million
visitors a year but they all have to
come at the moment by Road along the
busy and congested a38 so could I ask
the Prime Minister that this rail
be upgraded to a passenger service
providing a valuable east-west
connection from Birmingham and which he
also allow me to take her personally
around the National Memorial Arboretum I
I of course recognize the important role
that the important role that transport
links play in relation to prosperity and
economic growth and our rail strategy
connecting people that we published
actually does look at how we can restore
lost capacity capacity where that does
unlock housing growth easiest crowded
route meets demand and does offer good
value for money of course it's for local
authorities and local enterprise
partnerships to determine whether a new
station or train service is the best way
to meet local transport needs but we're
work closely with local authorities and
local enterprise partnerships to take
forward the schemes which they're
interested in progressing and in
relation to the Arboretum I will of
course consider a visit in the future
and I think he's probably given me an
invitation it's very difficult to refuse
Marten day
Thank You mr. speaker UK officials at
Dover process 10,000 lorries every day
from the EU bringing in food medicines
and other goods
so has the UK government experiment on
Monday with 89 lorries McCain to carp
are given the Prime Minister confidence
and hot government's ability to handle a
new deal breaks it's doing exactly what
it is necessary and sensible for
government to do which is making the
preparations for no deal and ensuring
that we test those preparations but I
come back to the point that if the
Honourable gentleman is worried about
the consequences of No Deal
then he should back the deal
mr. Kenneth Clark mr. speaker it said it
seems to be plain to anyone who's
listened to the most the debates in this
house there is no majority for any
proposition on a future relationships
with the European Union in this House of
Commons except the majority that is
clearly against leaving with no deal I
propose to vote for the Prime Minister's
withdraw agreement but I doubt whether
it will pass and if it is passed we get
into a transition there is no majority
or consensus on what the government is
supposed to be negotiating for in the
years that will follow that will settle
our future political and economic
relationships with Europe so the Prime
Minister has to be flexible on something
so would she consider if she loses the
debate next Tuesday
moving to the obvious step in the
national interest of delaying or
revoking article
[Applause]
the Prime Minister first of all can I
say to my right honourable an only
friend that the he said that he
referenced the withdrawal agreement and
said that there was no position in
relation to what the future relationship
should be of course
the framework for that future
relationship in greater detail than many
had expected is set out in the political
declaration which is the instructions to
the negotiators for the future but the
thing in that in that circumstance it is
right that we consider the role that
Parliament would play as those
negotiations go forward in relate
ensuring that we get that future
relationship right I believe it is
possible to have that future
relationship which is deep enclosed with
the European Union but gives us the
freedom to do what we want to do which
is to have independent trade policy and
develop trade agreements and trade
arrangements with the rest of the world
John speller Thank You mr. speaker can I
welcome the crackdown on cold calling to
fleece pensioners out of their
hard-earned pension pots but isn't this
just dealing with the symptoms rather
than the underlying cause which is the
ill-judged free-for-all pension changes
introduced by our friend the previous
Chancellor George Osborne which gave the
green light to the shysters and the
Spears what you're going to do about
that what what the change is what the
changes that were made by by the
government and introduced by the
previous Chancellor of the Exchequer did
was actually gave pensioners more
flexibility and more freedom in relation
to how to use their own money and in
Jerrel Gilliam mr. speaker every member
of this house knows that drivers and
commuters want greater investment to
repair our roads and upgrade our
existing railway services
yet we are wasting money on a deeply
unpopular project where the management
has failed the costs are out of control
and which will end up costing the
taxpayer more than a hundred billion
pounds that's about 300 million pounds
per mile of trap why can't we face up to
reality Prime Minister and cancel HS -
and spend the money on the people's
priorities for transport rather than on
this overpriced project which will never
deliver value for money for the taxpayer
Minister I say to I'm right on will
friend first of all we recognize the
concerns that people have about their
roads particularly about issues like
potholes in their roads which is
precisely why my writer on Wilfred the
Chancellor of the Exchequer has made
more money available to address those
issues on the question of HS - what HS
HS - is not just about a high-speed
railway it's actually about ensuring we
have the capacity that is needed on this
particular route because the capacity on
the west coast main line
we've already reaching capacity we're
already seeing HS - spreading prosperity
it's encouraging investment it's
rebalancing our economy and that's ten
years before the railway even opens
we've seen 7,000 jobs created across the
UK and 2,000 businesses across the UK
delivering HS - and it will bring tens
of billions of pounds worth of benefits
to passengers suppliers and to local
communities up and down the route Sir
Edward Davie can I thank the Prime
Minister for her words about Lord
Ashdown our friend paddy paddy was loved
on these benches and I believe he was
respected across the house and across
the country and we will miss him deeply
mr. speaker an unusual thing happened
last night conserve MPs and option fees
United levers and remain errs United
United to back my proposal for a view of
retrospection in a law called the lone
charge which offends against the rule of
law and has caused misery to tens of
thousands of people so in her role as
First Lord of the Treasury were the
prime ministers agreed to meet with me
and a cross-party delegation of MPs to
discuss this new review into the lone
charge minister first of all I think he
was absolutely correct Lord Ashdown
the late Lord Ashton was deeply
respected across this house and across
Parliament as a whole and and widely
across the country - in relation to the
question that he's put about the review
on the issue on the lone charge here
yes I'd got the point that he was trying
to make but can I just make this point
he talked about opposition and and
government MPs uniting actually the
government accepted his review into the
loan charge and I think the first stage
might be for the Chancellor of the
Exchequer to sit down with him and a
group of cos party MPs to look at how
that review is being taken forward mr.
Ian Duncan Smith the speaker I'm not
going to ask about brexit you may be
pleased
[Applause]
and a Happy New Year to all of you as
well can I say I recently had the to my
run with an immense privilege of
shadowing doctor in Ron's ear at our any
department at which Cross Hospital it
was a humbling experience to witness the
dedication and fantastic skill of our
doctors and nurses but they work in
buildings that are now well over a
hundred years old and they know they
need better facilities now I have to say
to her that whilst the NHS the
department has set the development of
whips at the top of the North East
London priority in December they
announced our programs across London for
investment yet again North East London
was not included so can I asked my right
honourable friend please would she now
visit which Scots hospital would she see
how important and vital it is to the
area and which she worked with our
excellent health secretary and work on
the base of a fantastic announcement on
Monday to invest in those buildings and
those facilities issued an invitation
that it is I would certainly look at the
possibility of taking him up on that
invitation he makes an important point
at the end there about the announcement
that we made on on Monday my right
honourable friend
all right honourable friend the health
secretary has heard what he has been
saying about the particular requirements
of whips Cross Hospital and we'll be
happy to sit down and talk with him in
more detail about that and I'll
certainly look at my diary and look at
his invitation
laylamon paddy and in his final weeks he
was very concerned by the way that
brexit would play into Britain's place
in the world brexit is clearly for
example in Russia's Giorgio in
and it was chilly to hear blood Amir
Putin parroting exactly the words with
the prime minister on why we should not
be holding a referendum to quote fulfill
the will of the people meanwhile poll
after poll show there is a majority for
a referendum because people can see that
her flailing deal is not in our national
interest so whose side is this Prime
Minister on protein or the people's
Prime Minister I am on the side of the
people to whom this Parliament gave the
vote on the decision as to whether to
stay
and and we will be delivering and
respecting that referendum and
delivering on brexit maybe through
I'm delighted that we'd be able to
deliver in our manifesto commitment to
introduce an energy priced cat can buy
rights for friends outlined how this
price cat will benefit my constituents
across era wash yes can I say to my
honorable friend be the fact that the
energy price camp has now come in I
think it's a very important step that
this government has taken I think it's
something like 11 million households
will benefit from the price cap it will
in will be saving households money as a
result of what this government has done
because we recognize the concern people
had about energy prices and it's this
government that has acted to deliver and
her constituents in era wash will see a
benefit as a result
Jill furnace Speaker many of my
constituents are employed in the
Sheffield steel sector a beacon of
innovation and manufacturing yeah UK
steel the body representing steel
companies has been clear that a No Deal
would be nothing short of a disaster for
the sector
well the Prime Minister comfirm she will
not be so irresponsible as to consider
the option of a No Deal and reassure my
constituents who are worried about their
job from their future minister to the
Honorable lady that I absolutely respect
and recognize the role that the steel
industry is playing in the United
Kingdom as you know over recent years
government has taken steps to support
the steel industry she talks about the
issue of whether or not we should leave
the European Union without a deal I have
been working to ensure that we have a
good deal when we leave the European
Union that is the deal that is on the
table and anybody who doesn't want no
deal has to accept that the way to
ensure there is no deal is to accept and
vote for the deal you merriman thank you
very much mr. speaker
on Tuesday us be voting for the Prime
Minister's withdraw
the class the Prime Minister to consider
one particular aspect which I must
declare rather rash okay the question
from the Honorable gentleman must be
heard and as I scarcely heard what he
said I think the Honourable gentleman
should start again and deliver it yes he
should start again and deliver it in for
mr. Hugh Merriman
I wear my arsenal tie unfortunately the
terrorist is here not quite as
well-behaved as our in the emirate mr.
speaker as I was mentioning I will be
voting for the prime minister's deal on
Tuesday there is one particular aspect I
would like the Prime Minister to look at
which I have to declare a rather rash
financial interest it relates to page 33
of the withdrawal agreement where
citizens residency can either be
provided free by the UK government or
commensurate to existing cost I rather
foolishly in a brexit meeting in Bexhill
were so confident that this would be
free by the government that I offered to
pay the charge to one particular
European citizen who was not quite as
confident mr. speaker my question to the
Prime Minister is surely given this was
a decision by the UK public surely we
should be welcoming our friends our
neighbors our essential workforce from
the EU and offering this charge free so
that they can stay in this country at
our cost
Prime Minister to my honourable friend
obviously I recognize the concern that
he's raised the fee of sixty-five pounds
to apply for states under the scheme is
in line as for that with the current
cost of obtaining permanent residents
documentation and it will contribute of
course to the overall costs of the
system but applications will be free of
charge for those who hold valid
permanent residence documentation or
valid indefinite leave to enter or
remain and for children being looked
after by a local authority and when an
application where an application is
granted pre settled status under the
scheme the will from April 2019 be no
fee when they apply for settled status
and as I said in earlier in response to
another member the EU settlement scheme
actually will make it simple and
straightforward for people to get the
status that they need
Stephen Kenna Thank You mr. speaker this
week our cross-party group Norway plus
published common market 2.0 a clear plan
that respects 45248 mandate address his
concerns about free movement protects
jobs in maya Brabham constituency and
helps to reunite our deeply divided
country if the Prime Minister's deal is
rejected on Tuesday will she then give
the house the opportunity to vote on a
range of the options including common to
common market 2.0 and will she be giving
her bench is a free vote on those
options he knows I am working to ensure
that the deal that has been negotiated
by the UK government with the European
Union is voted positively on by this by
this Parliament because it is a good
deal it does what he wants it protects
jobs and security it also delivers
delivers in full on the referendum
result which is a key issue I believe we
owe it to people to deliver what they
wanted which was control of money
borders and laws and that's what that's
what the deal does Jack Lopresti Thank
You mr. speaker
can I thank my right honorable friend
for ensuring our manifesto commitment to
scrapping tolls on the seventh bridge
crossing this will put 1,100 pounds a
year into the pockets of thousands of
motorists many of which are my
constituents and Jesse agree this will
help transform the economies of the
southwest and South Wales I think this
is an important step that the government
has taken it is one that was advocated I
know by individual members and by the
Secretary of State for Wales and it will
indeed I believe have a very positive
economic effect a positive economic
effect on Wales but also a positive
economic effect on the southwest and
indeed on constituencies life I
honorable friends mr. grobet Thank You
mr. speaker the Local Government
Association has produced figures showing
that councils of all political
persuasions overspent their Children's
Services budget by 800 million pounds
last year the figure for Sheffield was
12 million pounds
this is totally due to the fact that the
number of children in care has risen to
a 10-year high and the light of that
pressure is the Prime Minister except
that the 84 million pounds over five
years offered by the Chancellor in the
budget is totally inadequate and without
extra funding either these vulnerable
children will not gather care they need
all the other important services such as
parks and libraries will get further
cuts at a time the Prime Minister has
told us that austerity has come to an
end
[Applause]
what can I say to the Honorable
gentleman he's quoted the 84 million
that was actually for a pilot which is
about keeping more children at home with
their families safely we did announce
overall an extra four hundred and ten
million at budget for social care which
includes children and spending on the
most vulnerable children has increased
by over 1.5 billion since 2010 but we're
also taking a number of other steps for
example the work that we're doing to
increase the number of children social
workers the appointment of the chief
social worker for children introducing
frontline and step up getting quality
candidates into social care careers
these are important steps the honourable
gentleman talks about money actually
it's about ensuring that the service
that is provided is the right one and
that's why we do it that's why we do it
across the board and that's why we're
looking at those issues around those
social workers
so David Amos further house to my entry
in the register of interest ever since a
former president guy whom introduced
democracy into the Maldives legitimacy
has been challenged and just like the
prophets of doom around brexit the
recent elections went ahead with no
violence and presidents Ollie was
elected with a great majority so would
my right honourable friend now redouble
her efforts to increase trade education
and Court rulings news that he will
welcome which is a new embassy is being
opened up a new embassy is being opened
up in the Maldives and we will of course
look to ensure what we can do as we look
around the world
relation to trade to see what we can do
to improve our trade with a number of
countries with Parliament to defeat so
no a regular feature of her government
she's lost a quarter of her cabinet and
117 of her backbenchers want her gone
have deal as as dead as the deadest dodo
has many more indignities can this Prime
Minister and juror before she realizes
that she is the biggest part of this
problem and for goodness sake just go
[Applause]
the the UK government has negotiated a
deal with the European Union which
delivers on the referendum result I know
the honourable gentleman doesn't want to
deliver on the referendum result he
wants he wants to ensure he wants to
ensure that the UK stays inside the
European Union at the same at this
talking about the economy at the same
time as he also supports taking Scotland
out of the union of the United Kingdom
which which is it much more important
economically for the people of Scotland
the people of Scotland know the
remaining in the United Kingdom is their
best future
main speaker volunteering services are
enormous ly important and none more so
than the RNLI who put their lives at
risk and often a rescuing people are
making perilous crossings to try and get
into this country as well isn't it time
that we looked at the funding associated
with the RNLI many people think it's a
service that is funded by the government
and it's time we gave some money to
lutely write about the absolutely vital
role that the RNLI play and of course
the are in her life as she says many
people don't realize the IRA non-ai
is entirely funded by voluntary
contributions and I would pay tribute to
all those across the country who raise
funds for the RNLI including if she may
allow me the branch Sonning branch in my
own constituency Rachel maskel
Thank You mr. speaker York has been in
shock as we have learned that 11
homeless people in our city died last
year and whilst we know this is an issue
across the nation we know substance
misuse services have been cut we know
the social housing hasn't been built in
our city and we know that mental health
services are desperately underfunded and
under star prime minister I don't want
to hear what you have done because
clearly is has failed I want to know
what you're going to do differently so
no homeless person dies this year
every death of someone well hopeless
homeless or sleeping rough on our
streets is one too many and that's why
you know we have the commitment in
relation to rough sleeping to entering
it by 2027 and having it by 2022 we've
committed she says she doesn't want to
know what we've done but we have
committed over 1.2 billion to tackle
homelessness and rough sleeping and she
mentions Mental Health Service and asked
what we are going to do in the future
what we're doing in the future is
putting an extra 2.3 billion into mental
health services to ensure that we're
providing those mental health services
for those people who sadly currently are
not able to access them all Scully
mr. speaker more Londoners voted to
leave the EU than voted for the current
mayor of London whilst he's swanee
around Europe talking about brexit
rather his responsibilities like crime
housing and transport it's my right on
my friend agree with me that if he does
insist on being a brexit diva he should
concentrate on telling his side
to actually vote for this deal
[Applause]
smile my friend I absolutely agree and
that what the mayor of London should be
doing is looking at what delivers on the
vote overall vote of the people of
London and what on the vote that my
honourable friend referred to in terms
of people's London and on what delivers
in a way that protects the best
interests of Londoners and that is to
vote for this deal
mahalia mr. speaker the Prime Minister's
had 20 dancing rebels has promised five
golden trade agreements and has had one
big defeat and yet she still can't find
her withdrawal agreement has she checked
her pear tree it was a good attempt but
Christmas happened a couple of weeks ago
dr. Julian Lewis according to that
invaluable website they work for you
dot-com the Prime Minister has assured
this house on no fewer than 74 previous
occasions that we will be leaving the EU
on the 29th of March
will she categorically confirmed today
that there's absolutely no question at
all of delaying that date
by Minister I'm happy to repeat what I
have said previously that we will be
leaving the European Union on the 29th
of March I want us to leave the European
Union on the 29th of March with a good
deal that's on the table my constituents
Sarah and Chris Cookson lost their
little boy Charlie in 2013 since then
they've devoted their lives to helping
other families and children with
life-limiting conditions via their
charity the Charlie Coupland foundation
on box indeed they give birth to Carter
John Cookson he had three cardiac
arrests in one day after a success
unsuccessful operation he is now
fighting for his life in need of a heart
transplant cart has only been given a
matter of weeks to live will the Prime
Minister join me today in real awareness
to help us find a heart for little
phoebe Cara join the Honourable lady in
commending the work that the cooks ins
have done with the Charlie's Cookson
Foundation in raising funds for those
children and babies with our threatening
conditions and I say I'm sure the
sympathies of the whole house are with
the family at this very very difficult
time obviously she's outlined some of
the specifics of the case but what I
will do is ensure that the relevant
minister at the Department of Health and
Social Care meets the Honourable lady to
discuss this issue further we do want to
change the culture and organ donation to
save more lives that's why we're
planning to introduce the new opt-out
system in England from 2020 and the new
law will be known as Max and Kira's law
in honor of Max Johnson who received a
heart from jerub-baal who sadly lost her
life in a car accident but it's a tragic
case that the Honorable later his
outlined and I'll ensure that a minister
from the department speaks with her
about it thank you
order
yes yeah yeah I will take one I was
going to take a point of order first
from Leila Moran so that's the end of
Prime Minister's Questions for now it's
just worth dipping back into the House
of Commons where the Speaker John Barrow
will be is taking points of order on
this occasion not on that amendment it's
coming from the Liberal Democrat Leyla
Moran I think it's probably worth just
staying with the Commons for now to see
what the reaction of the Commons is to
the decision of John Bercow to pick this
technical amendment which would restrict
the Prime Minister's timing on coming
back to the Commons if you lose conduct
we should expect
[Applause]
I did hear those words I did not hear a
particular member I did not see a member
mouth those words but I did hear those
words and what I order holder please let
me deal with this what I want to say to
the honourable lady is that I think it
was most unfortunate but that was said
people sometimes do say things
instinctively and rationally but it was
most unfortunate the honourable lady was
perfectly properly paying tribute to an
extremely distinguished former member of
this house and someone that many would
regard as an international state's
person what was said should not have
been said if the person who said it
wishes to take the opportunity to
apologize it is open to that person to
do so
I think it's a point of order mr. Andrew
Britton thank you sir I will apologize
remarks if at any offense was caused to
any members of the house the Honorable
gentleman would stand and I thank him
for what he has said yes indeed a point
of order mr. Peter bone-like mr. speaker
as you know I've always regarded you as
an exceptional speaker and the defender
of pollen which I continue to do so but
I also regard the clerks of the house in
exactly the same light now yesterday
late last night I went into the table
office to look at the business of house
number two motions to see what
shenanigans the government was going up
to and it had been published and I've
thought of making the proposal and
amendment to that but I was told that
would be totally out of order and that
there were no other amendments filed to
tell new order paper there isn't them on
what action might be taken I'm grateful
to the Honorable gentleman for his point
of order and first of all let me thank
you for his kind remarks that prefaced
his inquiry this is the first I've
learned of the matter and that makes it
difficult for me to give immediate
advice it is a matter upon which I might
need to reflect before giving him what I
would call substantive advice obviously
I was not aware of the Honorable
gentleman's visit to the table office of
which he has now informed me I
understand that he is telling me that he
was advised that the motion was
unamended and I don't know whether he
went into the table office before
all right honorable and learning
gentlemen the member for Bekins field or
after all I know is that in my
understanding the motion is amendable
they order order order order in my
understanding the motion is a mandible
I'm clear in my mind about that so
insofar as the vulnerable gentleman is
disappointed that he wasn't able to
table an amendment I understand that
whether there is an opportunity of him
to do so now